[Musique]
bonjour daniel marceline bonjour bonjour
aux auditeurs et auditrices vous êtes
avocate au barreau de martinique et vous
êtes plus précisément responsable de la
commission indivision de ce barreau
daniel marceline depuis juin 2016 des
avocats de lille multiplie les réunion
avec la mairie sur cette question de
l'indivision qui mine les familles les
municipalités l'économie on y reviendra
on va commencer par définir la division
qu'est ce que c'est l'indivision c'est
quand plusieurs personnes exercent des
droits sur un même bien immobilier qui
peut être un terrain des maisons
autrement dit il y as physiquement
plusieurs biens ou un seul bien mais
plusieurs personnes sont propriétaires
et il convient pour sortir de
l'indivision de dire qui sera en
définitive le seul propriétaire de ce
bien
donc c'est tout un processus n'y a pas
un division uniquement quatre décès
alors il ya une division par exemple
deux personnes qui n'ont aucun lien
entre elles décident d'acheter un bien
en commun c'est une indivision
un couple qui est marié sous le régime
de la séparation de biens décide
d'acheter quand même bien à deux c'est
le régime de l'indivision
mais ce qui pose problème à la
martinique essentiellement c'est
l'indivision successorale
alors les divisions qui minent les
familles les municipalités l'économie on
a dit on va détailler tous que sont la
mine les familles on le comprend
facilement mais c'est peut-être là que
c'est le plus difficile arrêt arrivé
quelque chose là oui tout à fait parce
que quand on râle une succession on ne
règle pas seulement une question
matérielle nous sommes frappés nous les
avocats de constater que lorsque les
clients viennent nous voir pour nous
soumettre leurs difficultés ils font
revenir à la surface des choses qu'ils
ont vécu lorsqu'il était très jeune et
quelquefois les blocages que nous
constatons s'explique parce que soit
l'on considère qu'il y a eu des
préférences à l'égard de membres de la
famille et celui qui bloque c'est une
façon quelque sorte même inconsciente un
de se venger et de montrer qu'il existe
alors qu'ils considèrent qu'il n'avait
pas suffisamment été prises en compte
il y a donc un certain nombre de
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
affectifs psychologique et sans soudure
le sens de l'avocat ça mais il faut le
comprendre déjà
pour comprendre la difficulté est non
seulement pour la comprendre mais pour
aider à trouver des techniques pour en
sortir parce que différents
professionnels interviennent et
traditionnellement on sait bien qu'il ya
le notaire et le géomètre et l'avocat
mais de plus en plus il y a maintenant
des médiateurs il y a des généalogistes
qui interviennent parce que ils sont de
nature à apporter un accompagnement pour
aider à la sortie de l'indivision c'est
pour défaire des ne vous savez les
problèmes à l'heure actuelle qui sont
dans l'indivision ce sont des noeuds des
noeuds juridique d une technique d une
psychologique et donc le bâtonnier
nicolas en créant cette commission et en
faisant un peu le pas lille est allé
voir toutes les municipalités c'est
parce que il a souhaité que le barreau
de fort de france apporte sa
contribution à la résolution d'un
problème social qui dure depuis trop
longtemps
alors dans l'est ne voulait pas citer
même peut-être tout simplement ses
héritiers oublier ses descendants
d'héritiers dont on ne connaissait même
pas leur existence jusqu'à un moment
c'est à dire que quelquefois on connaît
leur existence je ne sais pas où ils
sont il faut bien comprendre que souvent
à la martinique dans l'indivision
successorale
il s'agit de régler des succès plusieurs
succession parce que il ya peut-être
quelques fois 2,3 succession parce que
ce qui était propriétaire et les et ceux
qui sont leurs héritiers n'ont pas
souhaité partager puis ils ont dit
oralement
voilà nous sommes propriétaires de tels
biens puis je voudrais que les enfants
soient là et puis ils ont ils ont rien
fait de plus pour régler et puis c'est
quand on arrive à la troisième voire la
quatrième génération qu'on se dit il
mais il faut régler la question est donc
ça se négocie son très long bah oui
parce que à ce moment là effectivement
il faut rechercher les où sont les
héritiers parce qu'entre temps il ya des
personnes qui sont qui sont mortes ne
sait pas forcément l'avocat qui n'est
pas bon c'est pas forcément le notaire
qui refuse de faire son travail a pas du
tout et c'est vrai qu'on ne comprend pas
le
le public peut être ne comprend pas le
parcours de combattant que cela peut
représenter et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les avocats veulent être des
facilitateurs et pour permettre
justement d'aider à ce parcours
alors on a vu comment ça peut être très
compliqué pour les familles
autre conséquence de la division mais
pour la municipalité parce que souvent
on voit des ce qu'on appelle des dents
creuses dans les centres ville dans les
campagnes c'est peut-être moins visibles
ça existe des maisons qui tombe en ruine
tout simplement penser agir là dessus
oui tout à fait parce que la réalité
pour les communes elles ne peuvent pas
faire de plan d'aménagement puisque elle
constate qu'il ya une parcelle qui est
inoccupée ou qui a un bâtiment qui se
dégrade
mais comme le bien n'est pas n'a pas de
titre au nom d'une personne individuelle
elle ne peut pas par exemple procéder à
une expropriation
mais en attendant si cela fait des
années que ça traîne on peut pas par
exemple réquisitionnés et puis faire par
exemple potager je sais pas moi pour la
réquisition
c'est malheureusement on prend bien
mais ceux qui pensent que moi je crois
qu'il est plus important de venir danger
pour les maisons à côté par exemple
risquent de 110 oui mais ça alors là la
municipalité ont d'autres corps cours
d'abandon manifeste qui peut pas
permettre à ce moment là de pouvoir
enclencher toute une procédure pour
pouvoir acquérir sahel à sa technique
mais pour régler véritablement le
problème d'ensemble
je pense qu'il faut aider les
particuliers à trouver des solutions
pour sortir de l'indivision et comme
cela chacun ayant après son titre de
propriété et sera possible soit ces
personnes d'avoir d un aménagement soit
à une municipalité d'exproprier pour
pouvoir avoir un développement mais
j'insiste beaucoup sur le fait que et
c'est le but des opérations que nous que
nous faisons avec le baron c'est que les
gens quelquefois ne sont pas au courant
de tout ce qui est à leur disposition
du point de vue juridique il n'est du
point de vue technique pouf et du point
de vue financier parce qu'il ya des
aides à la sortie de l'indivision et
notre travail consiste beaucoup à
renseigner les gens sur ce qui était
alors
portait alors un cycle de conférence 4
des buteurs juillet 2016 on a dit à
cette marie plus exactement des réunions
qui connaissent un véritable succès
parce que cette question est importante
pour les martiniquais
c'est quelque chose qui m'a qui divise
les familles tout simplement oui c'est
il ya beaucoup de personnes ya des
milliers de martiniquais qui sont
concernés par la division n'avait pu
l'authentifier et bien écoutez je
regardais ce que disait la délégation
sénatoriale pour notre mère en juin 2016
qui a déposé un rapport au sénat sur les
questions de la division en outre mer
ont considéré qu'il y avait entre 26 et
38 % en martinique du foncier privé qui
étaient concernés par la division c'est
énorme c'est énorme moi j'avoue que j'ai
même été supérieure est retombé par
exemple sur la fiscalité sur
l'aménagement du territoire
bien sûr sur la fiscalité par exemple
lorsque les biens ne sont pas il n'y a
pas de personnes individualisé pour le
paiement de la taxe foncière
ça veut dire qu'elle n'est pas recouvrée
donc par conséquent il ya une perte
il ya une perte pour les pour les temps
est pour l'a vu tout à l'heure pour les
communes il n'ya pas d'aménagements sur
le 5e bâti ça pourrait peut-être donner
une certaine certains une certaine une
relance du bâtiment et travaux publics
pas tout à fait et pour les personnes ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'elles ont un avantage à sortir de
l'indivision parce qu'en ayant un titre
de propriété
elles pourront soit le donnait en
hypothèques si elles ont un projet
immobilier soit le transmettre à leur
enfant soit le construire donc il y a
dans le circuit économique
la mettre sur le marché par le biais de
d'aménagement de prêt ou de transmission
c'est bien qu'ils sont dans l'indivision
cela va donner du souffle à l'économie
alors les avocats sont allés voir les
magistrats y sont allés voir les
notaires ont été à la rencontre des
mairies pour tous ce cycle de
conférences
la solution viendrait peut-être de la
loi tout simplement vous rencontrez
c'est toutes ces personnes et vous allez
faire des propositions par exemple aux
futurs députés qui seront lues au mois
de juin mais a des choses à dire tout à
fait alors vous avez raison de souligner
le travail qui a été fait au niveau des
magistrats et aux différentes
conférences qui sont organisés en
commune
nous avons la présence de
d'un géomètre il n'y a pas que des
avocats donc les notaires et les jours m
répondent aussi aux questions puisque
c'est un ensemble
il est important de comprendre que les
professionnels ne sont pas en
concurrence
ils sont complémentaires et que l'avocat
ce qui est particulier en ce qui le
concerne c'est qu'il n'est pas là
seulement pour le procès mais il est là
pour le conseil parce que quand on va
voir un notaire le notaire ne peut pas
donner des conseils à tous les membres
de la succession puisqu'il est chargé de
la succession donc il peut pas
privilégier l'un plutôt que l'autre
tandil ça tout le monde le sait sont
peut-être pas peut-être pas et c'est
justement ce que nous voulons faire
savoir c'est que en demandant conseil à
un avocat vous pouvez avoir une
stratégie et quelquefois vous pouvez
avoir des écluses savez ce qu'on dit
c'est minable que l'agent tout
simplement et tout ça va pas qu'avant
ces noms d'abord c'est faux si vous
voulez au niveau de l'ailé noter par
exemple les ce qui est prévu c'est très
tarif est un donc par conséquent ils
peuvent pas demander ce qui est mais ce
qui est plus que la loi et les avocats
demandent effectivement des
consultations mais comme tout
professionnel se soucier d'une
profession libérale et donc elle est
payée pour le travail qu'elle fournit
et par rapport onu on n'imagine pas on
n'imagine pas ce que représente le
travail de d'études et de conseil dans
une succession parce qu'il faut lire des
idées at il faut dire des titres il faut
rechercher il faut écrire aux mairies il
faut écrire aux archives pour avoir des
pièces c'est un travail chacun est
maintenant individuellement c'est au
tour des pièces de alors donc vous
parliez justement d'aider à des sorties
de l'indivision vraiment facilité oui on
peut parler de la loi et est ce qu'avec
un peu l'addition de toutes les
rencontres que vous menez depuis juin
2016 à cette marie est ce qu'il ya des
spécificités martiniquais ce qui
pourrait être porté par nos
parlementaires à nous bien c'est la même
chose que dans la creuse à la belle
étoile au nom il faut absolument pas
comparer le problème d'indivision aux
antilles et le problème de l'indivision
sur le continent ça n'a ni même avec la
corse la corse qui a obtenu une
législation particulière
nous nous sommes les héritiers d'une
histoire une histoire qui a des
répercussions sur le patrimoine et qui a
des répercussions sur la filiation en
france continentale le
les le cadastre les hypothèques existe
depuis des siècles la filiation l état
civil existe depuis des siècles en
martinique
enfin aux antilles la filiation n'a été
stabilisé qu'il n'y a qu' il ya une
vingtaine d'années et donc par
conséquent il faut bien comprendre que
nous avons lorsque nous réglons les
questions d'indivision et c'est pour ça
que quelquefois c'est si douloureux à
faire un run une recherche de notre
passé pour pouvoir rechercher les titres
de propriété est ce que vous disiez la
plus grande difficulté c'est la
reconstitution des titres merci d'avoir
été avec nos daniel marceline on
rappelle que vous êtes responsable de
cette commission et division du barreau
de fort-de-france et qu' il rend
fonctions pour suivre la prochaine ce
sera grand la prochaine c'est fin juin à
schoelcher merci bonne journée madame
marcelline merci à vous
[Musique]